agora eu sou Fitness você fica feio você
tem que comer frango eu frango a coisa
você come você fala meu Deus por que que
eu comi outra coisa na vida eu vou comer
isso o resto da minha vida eu para que
que eu comia x-burguer passa duas
semanas você não aguenta vai ver frango
meu Deus do céu escuta um galo cantar eu
fico puto come frango fitness viu acaba
com a granja Ô filho você é o mal do
Frango falar a verdade tudo na cadeia
alimentar tem alguém que come alguém a
zebra corre do leão e o frango corre da
Graciele Barbosa e Léo Stronda O Felipe
Franca Juju salimentando Ele come frango
que eu acho que ele não tira nem as
penas pegou um frango assim igual ao Tom
e Jerry bota na boca Tira só os ossos
você sai caminhando e o frango vivo
ai eu morro agora eu vou entrevistar uma
pessoa muito especial entrevistado de
hoje é o like que você deixou nesse
vídeo